chaque fois qu'on lit que le cio est
intéressé a amené le sport électronique
aux jeux olympiques une série de
boucliers qui se lève
pour avoir des jeux vidéo aux jeux
olympiques vraiment pour plusieurs c'est
comme si on faisait entrer le loup dans
la bergerie en faisant la promotion
d'une activité sédentaire qui s'opposent
aux valeurs fondamentales de l'olympisme
telle que définie par pierre de
coubertin au dix neuvième siècle on
ouvre la parenthèse comme le fait que
les femmes ne pouvaient pas prendre part
aux olympiques parce que leur rôle c'est
de couronner les vainqueurs
on ferme la parenthèse de l'autre côté
il ya ceux qui disent que les super
athlète qui effectuent des centaines
d'actions par minute sont des athlètes
en raison de leur rapidité et de l'arac
ut combiné à leur entraînement
spartiates avec des nutritionnistes et
des psychologues comme les sportifs de
haut niveau parce que s'il y en a un
monde qui est similaire à celui du sport
c'est bien celui des jeux vidéo dans un
comme dans l'autre à 30 ans tué sur la
pente descendante
j'ai 34 ans pour les mêmes réflexes
la question maintenant c est ce que le
monde du sport toi avoir perdu espoir
non c'est sport électronique qui doit
avoir participé au traditionnel dans les
années 90 les sportifs rêvait de voir un
jeu à leur nom être créée ou si j'étais
un peu moins populaire que kengo refi à
être choisi pour la mouture annuel du
jeu officiel de leur sport de
prédilection comme marty turco
s'explique pas pourquoi elle est
chanteuse cleo philippaerts disparaître
mais maintenant à être jeu sur la
pochette c'est pas assez
ils ne veulent pas être sûrs ou dans le
jeu vidéo ils veulent être reconnus
parce qu'il joue il y a à peine quelques
années le phénomène de l'athlète joueurs
étaient au mieux
alik de tic et un angle facile à aborder
pour un journaliste sportif en panne
d'inspiration après le 49e match de la
saison
colony world joue à league of legends le
texte pour demain je travaille pour des
athlétiques et même les équipes avaient
peur que trop de fautes knight ne nuise
aux performances des joueurs
les boîtes de nuit tellement plus relax
mais maintenant fini l'anecdote fini la
part quantité d'athlètes ont maintenant
leur propre chaîne twitch où ils
combattent des milliers d'autres
streamer pour capter notre attention
s'accomplir uniquement dans le monde
sportif pour certaines personnalités
hyper compétitive c'est insuffisant et
il ne faut pas oublier que même s'ils
sont devenus par leur talent des
athlètes d
ils ont grandi maintenant en suivant
leur personnalité web favorites comme
moi vous ferez bastille et maintenant
qu'ils ont plus de renommé que nous deux
combinés pourquoi pas offert le pot de
plus et devenir soi-même stream 1 dans
un environnement où ça peut prendre des
années obtenir une audience de plus de
deux personnes
c'est sûr que ça peut être frustrant de
voir que neymar obtient plus d'un
million de visionnements en échouant
lamentablement partie après partie en
plus et même pour une baleine gonflable
dans un petit pot pourquoi les regarder
alors parce que c'est un accès sans
précédent à certains de leurs athlètes
préférés sans contexte un peu formel des
entrevues d'après-match
quoique pour certains comme myers
leonard y aurait peut-être fallu rester
au contexte un peu plus formelle des
entrevues d'après-match profond au final
le risque pour le sport électronique
c'est que le cio contrôler la plus
importante compétition de jeux vidéo de
la planète
mais le hic sport n'en a pas besoin il
est en progression partout sans l'appui
de cette vénérable institution il ne
faut surtout pas laisser le destin des
jeux vidéo dans les mains d'un homme qui
a grandi en s'excitant d'une bonne
partie de pong le pixel va-t-elle avoir
rebondi se dirige dans l'autre sens 0
joueurs à gauche quel mâle blanc faisait
messieurs quel match de prendre c'est
tout pour nous cette semaine mais petite
expérience si vous voulez ou non que les
jeux vidéo soit aux jeux à l'été dit
boulay avec des signes ou dans les
commentaires
a plus la pression comme
ah ah